We're almost there
with our tablet layout.
It's time to get this done.
We have two problems.
First, if you've tried this on
a Nexus 7, or other seven-inch tablet,
there's a good chance the detail view
isn't rendering in landscape mode.
The reason for this,
is that the grid view cannot solve for
the constraints we've given it.
And the reason why we don't have
enough room is that the design for
this view calls for
the toolbar to be placed in line with
the detailed grid, rather than above it.
The second problem is
a problem with elevation.
Our design calls for a shadow around our
detail view, but it's just not there.
Since we'd like this to have a shadow
on all platforms, not just Android L,
we can introduce another widget
from the support library, CardView.
CardView is a container that
casts a shadow around a view.
When we change the elevation of
the card, it casts a larger shadow.
Note that card view has its own
version of the elevation parameter.
We can also change the radius of
the corners of the card view to make
rounded shadowed rectangles.
Note that this works best on L,
due to the way we handle clipping
on the compatible version.
Because the card view is a layout that
draws stuff around other layouts,
it works a bit differently than others.
You can control the background
color of the layout,
the background color of the card,
the padding around the card frame,
and the padding inside the card frame,
between the card and its contents.
Since CardView is rendered in
Android L using elevation,
it's important to understand how
this impacts the rendering of views.
First of all,
a view at a higher elevation
obscures views at lower elevations.
If you have nested views,
if a view will obscure the parent,
you will also obscure all
children of the view.
Views that have transparent
backgrounds don't cast shadows.
Views that are contained within these
transparent views will also not cast
shadows.
Given these constraints, it's relatively
easy to create a view with elevation
that doesn't render the way one expects.
We're going to make extensive
use of relative layout,
to avoid having to add extra hierarchy,
which would prevent us from creating
the kind of shadows that
the design requires.
One more thing,
on pre-L versions of android,
card view doesn't clip contents to
the bounds of the curved rectangle, but
instead adds padding to avoid having
that content overlap the shadow area.
Since we have a dark background
on part of our card,
this makes a little white line show up.
Since the corner overlap looks more
benign than these white lines,
I recommend setting
cardPreventCornerOverlap = "false"
on our card views.